ual intended filing uh the bill seeks
the repeal of three sections that
currently authorize the unwarranted
seizure of firearms without any
semblance of due process under existing
statue 173 B4 temporary relief the law
permits the issuance of temporary or
emergency protective orders based on
nothing but a v vague allegation of
domestic abuse or
stalking in New Hampshire and elsewhere
these temporary restraining orders are
nearly always granted by judges even
when the petitioner does not even allege
any abuse or stalking the petitioner
simply ask the judge to approve the
temporary order these orders are then
executed without the defendant's
knowledge as a matter of routine police
officers generally seize all firearms
ammunitions and other weapons from the
subject of the
order the sections we propose to
eliminate are those that empower the
confiscation of firearms ammunition and
deadly weapons by a police officer based
solely on these temporary orders such
mandates Gravely infringe on
individual's fundamental rights without
the requisite due process or evidentiary
support we are challenging the notion
that mere allegations sometimes with
zero evidence should be sufficed to
strip an in individual of their
constitutional rights and personal
property the low threshold for issuing
such orders is dangerously akin to Red
Flag gun laws which have been a subject
of intense debate and legal scrutiny
notably the case of the United States
first uh rahami is currently pending
before the United States Supreme Court
after a decision from the fifth circuit
invalidating federal law prohibiting
individuals from possessing firearms
while under a restraining order casting
doubt on the constitutionality of
prohibiting IND individuals from
possessing fire Firearms while under
restraining order this case underscores
the pressing need to re-evaluate and
reform our approach to such sensitive
and impactful legal
instruments our objective is not to
diminish the gravity of domestic abuse
or the importance of protective orders
however we firmly believe that the
process of depriving individuals of
their natural and constit ially
protected rights must be approached with
the utmost rigor and respect for due
process the current mechanism which
allows for this uh precipitous and
unchecked removal of one's right to bear
arms un unified unverified assertions is
a glaring up front to the principles of
Justice we hold dear often times uh
after the execution of uh these
temporary orders the subject of the
order will retaliate and get a
protective order on the uh the original
accuser and then that uh person will
lose their rights to bear arms as well
uh when they're in a situation where
they may uh be some sort of abuse in
essence this bill fortified by its
accompany Amendment uh represents a step
towards safeguarding the constitutional
rights of our citizens while ensuring
that any actions to protect the
individual from harm are judicious
evidence-based and firmly rooted in the
principles of due process I urge you to
consider the profound implications of
current law and join me in supporting
this essential reform
uh and with that I will take any
questions from the committee thank you
thank you representative what is the
current status of the case you cited has
the Supreme Court granted CT your on it
do you know uh can you say that again
has the Supreme Court granted C on that
case yet to take it or is it still the
fifth circuit the fifth circuit has
already invalidated the law and the
Supreme Court will hear the case okay
thank you any questions for the
representative seeing none thank you for
your testimony thank you than you who's
next chair calls uh Pamela KY and
Martin good morning Mr chair members of
the committee my name is Pamela kyg and
I'm the public policy specialist at the
New Hampshire Coalition against Domestic
and Sexual Violence and I'm joined here
today with my colleague Jessica who's an
executive director from one of our
member programs and we're here to
represent our network of crisis centers
um as you know the Coalition is the
umbrella Organization for the state's 12
community- based crisis centers that
serve more than 14,000 survivors of
Domestic and Sexual Violence each year
um and that also includes victims of
human trafficking stalking and child
abuse um and I'm here today emphatically
oppose HB 1064 which is incredibly
dangerous legislation that would keep
deadly weapons in the hands of abusers
in New Hampshire um and I would also be
opposed to the proposed amendment that
was just brought forward now um and just
to quickly answer the question the FIS
circuit rahimi case has already had the
oral AR arguments in front of the
Supreme Court um so just kind of to
quickly overview just how dangerous this
legislation is more than half of all
domestic violence homicides in New
Hampshire are the direct result of
abusers um so that means that most of
these homicides involve a firearm or
deadly weapon um and offenders are
responsible like I said for the majority
of these homicides in our state so the
question that I would really like to ask
the committee this morning is why are we
even debating a bill that would keep
deadly weapons and firearms in the hands
of abusers this bill seeks to repeal a
crucial provision that currently exists
in New Hampshire's domestic violence
statute RSA
173b if this Bill were to pass police
would no longer seize an abuser's uh
weapons after an arrest for violating a
protective order even if the abuser used
the weapon to abuse or threaten their
victim this is outrageous especially
when we know that an abuser's access to
a firearm increases the risk of domestic
violence homicide
fivefold um when an abuser violates a
protective order this is a signal to
their community that they are
comfortable completely disregarding a
court order and that they are completely
breaking the rules um and the laws of
the state um and I think what's really
important to understand is that when a
domestic violence protective order is
granted a judge has already found by
clear and convincing evidence that an
abuser is an imminent and credible
threat to the victim's safety
um current law takes the crime of
domestic violence seriously and
recognizes that when an abuser knowingly
violates a protective order they pose a
significant risk and threat to the
victim in the public failur to remove
firearms and deadly weapons from the
hands of abusers will only lead to more
domestic violence cases more injuries
and deaths that are 100% preventable
under current law um abusers must be
held accountable for the violence
committed against their Partners family
members and children in recent weeks
communities across New Hampshire have
been reeling in the wake of several
horrific domestic violence homicides
passing this bill would send a clear
message to communities mourning their uh
these tragic losses that me members of
the New Hampshire legislature aren't
invested in the safety of their citizens
um just to kind of wrap up um we have an
opportunity to make our communities
safer and instead we are here this
morning fighting against outrageous
legislation that is trying to turn back
the clock to the
1970s a time when systems of
accountability for domestic violence
offenders were simply non-existent with
so many pressing issues facing victims
and survivors in New Hampshire it's
inexcusable that this bill is even Up
For Debate in 2024
uh long ago the state
legislature sorry recognized the
seriousness of domestic violence in our
communities and this bill is an open
invitation for future violence and has
no place in our state um I would also
just like to note that stalking and
domestic violence can be co-occurring
and when stalking is present in a
domestic violence uh situation the
victim is three times more likely to be
murdered by their abuser um I would like
good morning uh chair and members of the
committee my name is Jessica Von Martin
and I am the executive director of The
Crisis Center of Central New Hampshire
um our agency is the Domestic and Sexual
Violence agency serving marac County uh
our office is right here in conquer and
each year we serve between 1200 and 1500
unique survivors of violence that
includes people of all genders ages and
orientations as the leader of that agent
and an advocate against for domestic
violence survivors for almost 25 years I
am here today to express my strong
opposition to this bill as you can
imagine our team supports survivors in
their lowest moments we placed 49
individuals into emergency shelter this
year last year helped 11 families flee
the state due to safety concerns and
supported the filing of more than 140
domestic violence protective orders in
2023 our staff and volunteers he daily
the stories of violence that people face
and the fear in their voices protective
orders are one of the few ways survivors
can create protection around themselves
and their families and this bill as
written would effectively remove those
protections and increase the likelihood
of injury and death in our state to
domestic violence for example a recent
example a woman we were supporting to
get a protective order which was not
granted on the first time around I will
add was living in a basement and would
not leave her house until she received
confirmation that all weapons had been
confed ated by local law enforcement the
perpetrator had multiple guns which he
had held to her head several times
before she
left she was so fearful of being found
she stayed hiding in that basement for
more than 3 weeks refusing to leave for
food work or anything in this instance a
tragic outcome was avoided but what
could have happened if he was able to
hold on to his weapons if perpetrators
are allowed to keep their guns after
that kind of behavior these are the
lengths survivors will need to go to
keep themselves and their family safe we
already know as Pamela said that many
homicides in New Hampshire are related
to domestic violence therefore I asking
this committee to oppose this bill so we
are not adding to those numbers thank
you for your time and consideration of
this bill and the work you do to keep
New Hampshire
safe I'm happy to field any questions
representative
Newman yeah I have a question we in the
previous testimony we heard that these
orders are based on
allegations and we also heard that um
there's no due process and a lot of
times we hear that these guns are
confiscated do you have any comments on
on those uh those allegations sure I
will share with you that although we
supported 140 domestic violence
petitions in Marram County last year
many many many were not granted and so
there is an there is a matter of due
process and there does need to be
compelling evidence of an eminent threat
yeah um only about about a third of
final protective orders are granted in
the state the process to receive a
protective order is extremely stringent
and has a high bar like I mentioned
there needs to be clear and convincing
evidence of a credible present threat to
the victim's safety um and that includes
173b if you could um a second could you
tell us um about how long the period is
from the original order to the hearing
order so from the temporary protective
order to the final hearing usually it
needs to happen within 30 days and
typically is within that time frame so
normally Firearms are seized on the
temporary order and held at least until
the final order hearing is held at that
time is it your understanding that if
the order is not granted the Firearms
are
returned yes but the uh the temporary
restraining order has the same uh
credible present threat standard so it's
not like there's the same standard it's
the same criteria except for one is X
parte the the defendant isn't present at
the temporary order correct that's
usually done yeah and I know that there
are some folks behind me that can better
answer some of those uh legal questions
thank you representative Newman your
follow-up question oh okay um further qu
representative sing thank you for taking
my question um I'm curious of the
domestic violence homicides that occur
in New Hampshire um what percentage of
those are um does the perpetrator use um
what we would consider a deadly weap
weapon firearm or ammunition it's about
50% it fluctuates every um couple of
years but it pretty stays pretty evenly
axelman hello thank you very much so um
my basic understanding is there was
miscommunication with the sponsor NOS
the intention was to strike not that
part a different part
um there are a few different parts
different sections of RSA
173 the uh primary statute that
authorizes the restraining orders which
function as red flag laws um one of the
parts directs law enforcement to take
possession of all firearms ammunition
and weapons initially when the order is
served and that's an emergency order
temporary order and then um then we go
from there to the final order another
section of RSA 173
says if a person violates the order um
continues to abuse the person with the
protection order and they're arrested
then police can do certain things
including cease Firearms which is
redundant um my my understanding as a
sponsor did not even mean to strike that
part that's fairly reasonable if you're
arrested for violating it um it's the
initial serving of the order um to to
correct some of the the previous uh
testimony the big thing that there's
disagreement on is uh due process but
also how easy it is to get the orders I
have some evidence in in the folder here
I'll share with the committee and we can
make copies um that prove with you know
the judge's signature that these uh
emergency orders and temporary orders
are granted with I think someone said an
extremely high bar I would say an
extremely low bar but actually
non-existent so if you look at RSA 173
which is the statute that creates the
restraining order and RSA 633 stalking
kind of points to that statute for the
uh criteria so really 173 is the primary
statute it says there should be a threat
there should be you know some evidence
or uh an allegation saying hey that
person uh either stalked me or did
domestic violence there have been cases
which you know I have uh proof evidence
of with the judge of signature where a
person did not even make an allegation
just said I want an order I didn't make
an allegation said I want to be
protected from this person and the judge
approved it and then um police went to
the person's home seized about um a lot
of uh Firearms amunition from that
person and relatives and other firearms
that were in that property and that
person is now out um a substantial
amount of their net worth and um that's
a taking as far as eminent domain scotus
case law says that's obviously taken by
a long shot they took the property um as
far as getting it back there's another
bill that representative Manion put in
um to give it back but you don't get it
back right away so the at the final
hearing um previous PE testimony was
correct that the final hearing there
should be a higher bar to and that's for
a year so within 30 days you get a
chance to go to court and have some due
process and then the judge is supposed
to uh have a higher bar to approve the
order for a year and then if it's not
approved the order is uh dissolved but
then to get your Firearms back you have
to go again to a different judge get a
lawyer go to a judge ask for a court
order to compel the police to give your
guns back and then you can go to the
police station and then um generally you
have to pass a next background check
you'll have to prove that all the
firearms and amunition is yours based on
serial numbers uh registration receipts
and all that stuff and according to RSA
173 I believe according to the state law
New Hampshire police can charge you fees
for every day and I've heard of some
exorbitant uh stories of of the fees
amounting to to ridiculous numbers for
for doing the privilege of holding your
property for you and it says they could
damage your firearms and ammunition and
lose and lose them with impunity so
that's interesting too um so people are
losing value and again what this allw
comes down to is is very simple is a lot
of people said you know they are abusers
we have to protect victims from abusers
there's a reason do process exists um if
some people think the founders were
brainless for writing the Fifth
Amendment I would disagree there's a
reason the Fifth Amendment is there
there's a reason we have courts it's to
adjudicate guilt if we're going to
presume people guilty based on one
person's extremely low bar um allegation
or in some cases no allegation Justus
request for an order which can ruin a
person's life for a lot of reasons um
that order there's a reason you judicate
them as guilty so others today have said
all others elsewhere I've heard say do
you want people who have guns and beat
their wives and stalk people and use
guns and shoot their wives to have guns
and have freedom and never be punished
no like someone mentioned a person put a
gun to their wife's head absolutely that
person should be very swiftly arrested
prosecuted convicted it could all happen
within a day uh you know two days 3 days
and then put in prison for however long
the sentence is um but if we're going to
skip that and punish them arrest them
take their firearms punish them um
convict them essentially then why do we
have courts so what I would propose is
getting rid of Courts we could save
taxpayer money we all love that get rid
of Courts when police go to a home
they'll declare the person guilty throw
them in jail or prison and um it'll be
more efficient why have courts so I
would ask any opponent to the bill why
do we have courts is to adjudicate guilt
there's a reason we have due process
there's a reason the founder said we
have presumption of
innocence we're supposed to be presumed
innocent and and I think everyone of
this committee understands that if
someone commits an act and and we've
seen you know the Boston Marathon
bombers people um committing 911
terrorism like murder and Broad day
light still they're Presumed Innocent
you can't even call them a criminal you
have to say alleged criminal otherwise
they Su for defamation right you can't
even call them convicted um so some
would even say the statute calling them
a victim is like saying the person is a
convict that's they should be alleged
victim alleged uh criminal alleged
abuser CU there's been zero de process
um something else that that maybe we'll
get to in another bill or an amendment
or a later year is there are remote
hearings so the the emergency and
temporary order granted by a judge um
telephonically a a cop calls a judge in
2 second signature um and then it's
approved and the cops take the firearms
and stuff um they say you know we can't
waste any time we can't waste a second
the person we have to take their guns
they're dangerous and forget do process
we don't have time for that um we have
video and I know this because in New
Hampshire courts and all over in federal
courts they have remote testimony so why
couldn't an amendment to this bill or a
new bill why couldn't the judge when he
gets the application for the order since
they have all the info on that sheet
anyway with the address and phone number
and all that of the subject of the order
the defendant why can't they contact
them and at least ask if they would like
a remote hearing to defend themselves um
and you know they can appear Maybe via
remote hearing and defend themselves and
have some due process so that could
happen we have the technology we could
do that easily um so those are a few of
my big points I'm happy to take any
questions anyone has any
concerns any questions for the um
much the chair calls The Honorable
love
thank you Mr chair and thank you members
of the committee uh for the record my
name's representative David love I
represent Rockingham 13 which is Derry
and uh I uh I guess I could you could do
some a little personal experience um you
know back in 2005 my uh my ex-wife took
out a restraining order on me I never
laid a hand on her um and uh you know
she had no no reason to uh 5 days later
I was uh allowed to have a hearing they
had taken my guns by the way and uh you
know they they gave me a hearing and my
lawyer walked up to her and uh at the
time there was a perjury statement on
the bottom of the restraining order that
she had to sign and uh my lawyer walked
up and said look we can prove you you've
lied we'll press perjury charges if you
don't resend this right away she did
okay you know proof that these
restraining orders are used as a weapon
okay um a few years later there was a a
hurricane forecast and stuff and uh I
had uh been helping this uh this Vietnam
vet and uh he was he he had some mental
problems and he had a Jeep with a rag
top on it and he came by my house and he
said can you help me put the rag top on
and uh you know before the hurricane so
you know we did and uh when the
hurricane came it blew the rag top off
and uh he came to me and you know he was
serious as a heart attack he said you
owe me
$800 so I laughed at him you know and
that you know he got all kinds of mad
and he went to to the Der district court
and convinced the judge that uh that on
the restraining order it said that I was
looking to take over the country I owned
uh many guns I was a bodybuilder I get
one of these things you I'm a
bodybuilder like uh like a hole in the
head but anyway um you know um you know
it it was a lie once again he went down
to the clerk's office to get the
paperwork after the the hearing and
there were two two men there that I that
I knew and uh he just uh he stood there
and he looked at one of them he knew he
knew him too and he said said uh you
know good it's almost hunting season and
I got his guns taken away once again
used as a weapon okay uh I beat that
again on the five day thing uh but at
this time there was no perjury statement
on the on the on the form okay which I'd
like I'd like to see an amendment to
that uh but anyway uh getting getting
back to the uh the bill um you know the
uh an abusive spouse or anybody uh can
can use a car a steak Knife you know the
use planes and you know uh you know uh
you know the the bombs they used down in
in Texas our way back when U you know we
if you want to kill somebody there's a
lot of ways there there's men on this
committee could that could kill a 120 PB
woman with their bare hands so what are
you going to do handcuff everybody you
know handcuff somebody uh you know
without due
process uh this this what we've been
doing is absurd it's a it's a violation
of the Second Amendment and our our our
uh article 2A in the New Hampshire
Constitution um you know we we need Pro
due process you know I I was guilty of
nothing in either one either one of
those cases yet I lost my my rights to
to have to to keep in bare arms um you
know uh it was the the first case with
my ex-wife it took me eight weeks to get
my guns back okay uh you know I had to
file for another court hearing and uh
you know go through all that and uh you
know after eight weeks they had to give
me my guns back uh the second time uh a
member of this committee at the time uh
representative guy ktoa had uh
introduced a bill and had passed uh to
reduce that to 21 days so 21 days after
after that 5-day hearing I I got my guns
back um once again though you know if if
it's 10 minutes it's constitutional
violation you know and uh you know if we
if we allow the government to uh to
abuse any of our constitutional rights
you know which one's next you know where
do we go from here you know and and if
it's if they're going to if they're
going to uh you know take our Second
Amendment rights away they'll take any
right away and uh you know the the
Second Amendment is there to protect the
rest of them and uh you know um I I I
just think that uh all along we've been
doing doing an injustice you know the
freedom and uh you know it' be nice to
changed thank you representative I I
have a uh just a couple of quick
questions with regard to your personal
uh
incident
um they could you explain to us the
process about getting your Firearms back
um there was previous testimony that you
had to prove after they took your
Firearms did they give you first did
they give you a receipt indicating what
they had taken and did you were you
required to prove ownership of each
firearm no I wasn't required to prove
fire ownership uh on the first one uh I
there was a a shotgun barrel that I
never got back you know they they did
not give me a list of what they took um
the second the second time they did uh
you know the second time they were much
more professional about it and um you
know uh but uh you know and that that
varies from from town to town
jurisdiction to jurisdiction it depends
who you're dealing with I guess and will
you charge any kind of storage fee
no any further questions to
representative representative Pratt now
when you went to court to get your your
property back after you were found not
guilty uh did you have to get a lawyer
to do that or did it cost you money the
first time I had a lawyer yeah so that
cost you money yes yeah and uh the
second time I I went uh you know uh
prosay and uh you know I I had Witnesses
including a dairy police officer as to
what was going on I I I was real
confident that I was going to win and
you representative
Muse thank you for taking my question
what was the disposition of the domestic
violence charges that were brought
against you uh I didn't have uh domestic
CH domestic violence charges just the
restraining ERS just a restraining a
thank
you I I would like to add you know going
back a little bit that uh you know my uh
my my brother and his ex-wife were had a
contentious uh marriage and stuff she
she attempted to run him over with a car
okay once again you know that that kind
of stuff is is it happens too so how do
we stop that there's many ways to kill
somebody no it does you don't need a
gun thank you um see no further
questions thank you for your testimon
thank
you chair calls attorney Steven ards and
Paul
hson
good morning members of the committee my
name is Steven Andis I'm an assistant
County attorney in the maram county
attorney's office with me is attorney
Halverson who is the Marat County
attorney both of us have been
prosecutors um for a little over 20
years
each listening
to uh we oppose this bill uh listening
to what's been said it seems like
there's a lot of focus on on the abuser
instead of the
victim um I hear people talking about
constitutional rights and the founders
and and their their their thoughts I
would I'd remind the committee that part
one article three of the New Hampshire
Constitution indicates when men enter
into society they surrender up some of
their natural rights to that Society in
order to ensure the protection of others
and certainly uh Society has an
obligation to protect people
and in this case Society has an
obligation to protect
victims it there is a balance between
protecting victims and victim's rights
to be safe and an abuser's right or a
person's right to to keep in be arms
certainly 173 B4 seems to
recognize um those competing interests
and sets forth a
framework there there is due process in
173 B4 to have your Firearms seized
by um law
enforcement for a temporary order there
needs to be a showing of immediate and
present danger of abuse that's someone
has to go in front of a judge a judge
has to make that finding and then the
judge issues a temporary restraining
order that temporary restraining order
may it doesn't require but it may direct
the uh defendant to relinquish firearms
and deadly
weapons most temporary restraining
orders in my experience have included
that provision because that provision
certainly makes sense if somebody is uh
an immediate and present danger of abuse
then it makes sense that a court would
ask that they relinquish their firearms
it's important to note that that's a
relinquishment of firearms it's not a
surrender of firearms the the defendant
still owns those firearms and as we've
talked about there is a process to get
those back which is also outlined in 175
B5 and in addition to the process to get
them back within 173 B5 if you don't
want the police department storing your
Firearms you can file a motion and have
your Firearms transferred to a federally
licensed Firearms dealer you can sell
those guns you can keep those guns you
can transfer them to another person you
can do all of that while this temporary
order is pending against
you in terms of how long the temporary
order is is valid for I would note that
currently in 173 B4 if an exp parte
temporary order issues the defendant the
person against whom that order was
issued can request a hearing and a
hearing shall be held within three but
no later than five business days so this
is not an extended relinquishment of
firearms this is you get a hearing
within 3 to 5
days at that hearing the the the
permanent order under 173 B5
there needs to be a showing of abuse by
a preponderance of the evidence the
defendant is given notice of that
hearing and has a right to be present at
that hearing and has a right to present
their own testimony at that hearing if
the court makes that finding of abuse
then the court shall order
relinquishment of firearms which is
law looking at the original bill I was
confused because it certainly didn't
change the relinquishment of firearms in
temporary or permanent restraining
orders I understand there's an amendment
the amendment that I'm looking at at
least
today um still deals with 173 B4 which
is the temporary orders but still
wouldn't address 173 B5 which would be
permanent restraining ORD so under a
permanent restraining order there would
still be a relinquishment of
firearms but certainly there is a
balance in the statute and the stat
statute seems to recognize that not sure
if you had anything to add not to that
so far that's all I've got that's all I
got yeah I do have a couple
things I don't you want to ask attorney
ERS questions before thank thank you
morning chairman Roy morning committee
members um I'm not going to add uh
repeat what attorney endes covered uh I
think he outlined the statute fairly
well I do want to comment on a couple
things uh that was testified to earlier
and some of the questions that the
committee had um the case versus RI
about the Rami case out of the fifth cir
uh fifth Circuit Court I actually spent
a couple hours last night reading
through the riyami case oral arguments
were last fall uh and I looked through
um there were about 40 or so amicus
briefs filed in Rami I've looked through
a number of them looked through the
facts of the original case involving Mr
Rami and I just want to com comment
about what happened to Mr rami's case
because I think it's important Mr Rami
um and his girlfriend had an argument in
the parking lot he assaulted his
girlfriend in the parking lot fired a
round out of a firearm in that same
parking lot uh he left uh later
threatened to shoot her if she had told
anyone about the incident in the parking
lot uh she the girlfriend fire filed a
request for a restraining order it was
granted it was granted after a hearing
after due process for a period of two
years and I'm reading out of one of the
U uh uh one of the five ings at the
Supreme Court uh that filing summarizes
Mr rami's uh continuing Behavior Uh the
court found that riyami had had
committed Family Violence and that such
violence was likely to again in the
future the court accordly prohibited
riyami from from committing Family
Violence or from threatening harassing
or approaching his girlfriend or her
family it also suspended his handgun
license now I'll paraphrase it suspended
his handgun license prohibit him from
owning a firearm um uh but he went on to
later violate that uh he participated in
a series of five shootings in December
of 2020 and January
2021 uh after someone who had bought
drugs from him started talking trash is
the quote on social media he went to the
man's home and fired bullets into it
using a rifle the next day uh after
colliding with another vehicle he got
out of his car shot at the other driver
and fled 3 days later he uh fired a
firearm in a residential neighborhood uh
without striking anybody luckily uh
couple coule weeks after that a truck
flashed his headlights at Mr Rami on the
inter on on a roadway during when he was
passed Mr Rami chased that truck down
misidentified another vehicle and fired
into that vehicle well that's what
brought Mr Rami uh before the um before
the federal court for possession of a
firearm in violation of 18 USC 922 uh if
anyone deserve to be in front of the
court it appears from the from the
summary of the record that it it's
probably Mr rihani um the question comes
then and I Circle back to what attorney
Andress said is is the focus here on the
Violator or the alleged
violator or the safety of the individual
and um I agree that uh that at times uh
with enough due process that we need to
protect the victims in in these cases
that's that's clear I spoke with many of
the County attorneys either directly or
by email and everyone I talk to is
opposed to this bill I'm sure they would
be opposed to the bill in the amended
format uh I understand from talking with
virtually uh all the Chiefs by email or
by uh telephone uh in marama County all
of them are opposed to this bill I'm
sure they would oppose it in its amended
form um I believe the association Chiefs
of police may also be in opposition to
this bill and I think they file written
written documents
um it's it's worthy to note to attorney
andw touched on on this surrender or
confiscation big difference uh it's my
understanding even under federal law a
person can have an ownership interest
but may not be able to possess a firearm
um that's addressed within 173 regarding
the return of firearms even in 173 B9
when it talks about a violation of a
protective order in paragraph um Roman
one subparagraph B it talks about uh the
law enforcement agency shall maintain
possession uh until the court issues an
order direct that the Firearms
ammunition or other deadly weapons be
relinquished and specify to whom the
person uh or U uh the Firearms will be
relinquished to the court in 2023
updated their their protocols on just
this very issue chapter 14 of their
protocols within the court spells out um
the due process requirements of
returning Firearms how they're returned
to whom they're returned the hearings
that are required and as part of their
statutory references they go through the
New Hampshire Constitution part one
article 2A they talk about RSA um
convicted felons false imprisonment sale
of handguns uh penalties for attempts to
purchase firearms temporary relief final
relief under
173b uh violation of protective orders
under B9 173 B9 uh and they go on to uh
uh address that so there is due process
throughout the application procedure the
initial issuance of a temporary order
hearing for issuance of a final order
relinquishment of firearms not s not not
uh uh not confiscation but a
relinquishment during dependency of a
domestic violence restraining order or a
protective order and then a final
disposition of those Firearms either
when the individual is no longer covered
by the protective order or wishes to
transfer to a u federal firearms uh
dealer like attorney Andrus mentioned
for subsequent disposition by by sale uh
I'll submit this afternoon because I
only found it late last night an article
that came out in uh the Journal of law
of medicine and ethics it came out in uh
the spring of 2023 it goes through some
of the uh some of the numbers uh and the
dangers to victims of domestic violence
uh involving Firearms violence uh the
title of the article is intimate partner
violence firearm injuries and homicide
uh I'll email that to the committee
later on this this morning for your
consideration but one comment in that
that I'll end with talks about the
relinquishment of firearms and in that
article the author mentions roughly half
of states have addressed a gap talking
about a surrender Gap in federal law at
the time
um by including specific state
requirements for surrender of firearms
upon imposition of permanent restraining
orders uh and it talks about that within
the article I commend that article to
you for for your reading and review for
statistics and um and overview about the
uh uh about the reason and need for
these types of statutes uh I'll gladly
answer any questions uh and uh have any
the
only the only thing I would add is in
reference to the returning of firearms I
know both attorney Halverson and I have
handled those hearings on behalf of the
state so we're happy to answer questions
about that as well certainly thank you
that's actually my first
question is it the current state of the
law that if a permanent order is granted
that someone is required to go for a
separate proceeding to get their
firearms back and why is that versus
just simply saying the ORD is not
granted here are your Firearms back why
is the why is the the alleged uh
perpetrator required to go through a
separate legal
proceeding 173
B5 uh section
10c says law enforcement agencies shall
not release firearms and ammunition and
specified deadly weapons without a court
order granting such release so the
statute requires the police to have a
court order to Grant a
release I guess my question is why when
the judge says I'm not going to Grant
this permanent order and hereby order
the return of the Firearms why is there
a second it's an expense to the to the
person to have to go get an I mean other
than the fact that we wrote the law
right I mean that's what the law says I
I don't know what the background of that
particular sentence in the statute is
nor do
I it just seems to me if the it would
only make sense that if the the judge
doesn't find reasonable grounds to issue
the the person should just have their
property back without having to an
expense of another hearing yeah there's
some there's some interesting statutes
because it also talks about when police
acquire property through any means that
they have to hold it as the court
directs um so we've certainly had
you know controversies over how long
does something have to be in the police
possession before we need a court order
to return it um also to the best of your
knowledge is there any uh requirement
that a receipt an itemized receipt be
given by law enforcement to someone when
they seize their property I don't
believe there's a requirement for an
itemized receipt all of the Departments
that I've ever worked with are very um a
afraid I think of being accused of
damaging property or losing property so
it's the type of thing where if they if
you have money in your pocket they're
going to count it in front of you twice
and have you sign that that's what the
money is so all the Departments I've
worked with have always kept an
inventory of exactly what's taken um
I've always seen itemized lists of
exactly what's taken as have I I I just
simply have concerns if I had to prove
that I own something that they took up
from me um and go back can find receipts
from something I bought 15 years ago
we'd be in problems I I've never had
any I shouldn't say I've never had any
issue of ownership because I I actually
have a case now where a third party is
claiming that it was their gun that was
seized and they want it returned to them
instead of the the defendant there's a
presumption that property seized from a
person is owned by that person
right and if multiple people live in one
dwelling all the firearms in the
dwelling are seized and then it's up to
the individuals to go and kind of prove
that was mine and not theirs and then
they can't bring it back to the dwelling
how how does that
work I don't believe all the firearms in
the dwelling would be seized it's the
firearms that are owned or under the
control of the person who the protective
order has been issued against um if
those Firearms were able to be accessed
by that person potten potentially they
could be seized but I would assume that
uh you could restrict access within the
dwelling um representative rhods thank
you Mr chairman uh my first question was
going to be about an
itemized inventory if you will so with
that question already being answered
could you perhaps walk us
through like say this you know the
person is is the clear and convincing
evidence has been found and going to go
into this home and or place of residence
and they're going to seize this property
could you walk us through what that
process is or how they go about saying
you know is there things in this closet
or they under the bed or I I've never
been personally involved in that process
um my understanding from reading the
statute and from talking to police
officers over the years is that they
would say to First they're going to have
a conversation with the victim and say
does this person have any firearms and
then they're going to have a
conversation with the defendant and say
do you have any Firearms um if so this
order requires you to relinquish them to
us we've certainly had cases where
defendants say nope I don't have any
Firearms the police don't then search
the house they're not ransacking it
looking for firearms because the statute
doesn't authorize them to do it it
authorizes them to essentially receive
from the defendant those firearms and
the court orders the defendant to give
them over having said that if the victim
says yeah he's got a gun he has a
handgun in the nightstand handgun in the
nightstand handgun in the nightstand and
the defendant says nope no handgun in
the nightst I have always told the
police what you need to do is obtain a
search warrant um because you have
probable cause to believe he's violating
the protective order if you have
probable cause to believe there's a
firearm in the nightstand so depending
on what you're being told um you would
then get a second warrant which would
authorize you to search the residents um
for firearms and that's address in 173
B5 Roman 2 uh the defendant should be
prohibited from purchasing receiving or
possessing any deadly weapons and any
Firearms or ammunition for the duration
of the order the court May subsequently
issue a search warrant authorizing a a
police officer to seize any deadly
weapons specified in the protective
order and any and all firearms and
ammunition if there is probable cause to
believe that firearms and ammunition are
kept under the privilege of presidence
or curtilage of the defendant so they
have to go through another due process
so thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question are you aware of a
provision where a nixus or background
check is required by the police even
though there's a court order from a
judge saying to relinquish those
Firearms when the person shows up at the
police station are they now required to
go through a criminal background check
as well before the police release the uh
guns or
ammunition I'm not aware of a
requirement for that um I know that I in
my experience there have been individual
police departments who will want to run
the record a second time um but I don't
know that that's required I think the
courts and I I can't put my finger on I
think the courts may run on domestic
violence cases do a next check but that
was if I'm not mistaken was that
challenged yeah my understanding is that
if the motion to return Firearms if the
motion return weapons is firearms that
gets sent to the state police who do um
a NYX check if it's non firearm deadly
weapons like if we seized a crossbow or
that type of thing then it goes to the
local police department to run a a
right representative
Newman thank you and thank you for
taking my question um we often hear that
expar hearings are unconstitutional and
they don't provide due
process um um do you have any comments
on that why it is and I've also read
that that that it is a waiver to doe
process as opposed as providing due
process in temporary temporary instances
where there's a government uh need for
that so could you just comment on that
and kind of help us straighten that out
and what supports that as
constitutional I'm I don't know of
necessarily a constitutional provision
that specifically allows expart hearings
I think as a matter of sort of reality
you have to be able to do something
quickly in certain
circumstances and throughout case law
they've developed standards for expar or
temporary restraining orders and
interestingly those standards tend to be
higher than for a a a permanent order
because at the permanent order the other
party is
present as I read 173 B4 I actually
think that there's a higher standard to
receive a temporary restraining order
than there is under 173 B5 to receive a
permanent restraining order and that
makes sense to me that there's a higher
standard for the temporary order because
it is
xar so I think that throughout you know
case law and jurist Prudence they've
developed these standards for for an
expart hearing which have withstood
constitutional
scrutiny thank
you with regard to um the
the case law I believe that is there
more civil case law that kind of backs
up the exart than criminal for example
in a u motion to dismiss is the standard
not always right in light most favorable
to the non-moving party who's not
available yeah in in civil cases you can
get um you know restraining orders
temporary orders and generally the you
have to show that there'd be irreparable
harm if there's not an immediate order
um and that you're likely to Prevail on
the merits to
essentially stay the proceeding or keep
things the way it
is and for all intents and purposes
although it falls within the criminal
statutes it's a civil proceeding this is
a civil proceeding yes it's the
violation that falls in the criminal mov
it into the criminal world thank you
representative
s thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question um just having looked
at some of the online testimony as well
um one of the things that's come up and
I don't know if you're the best person
to answer this or perhaps one of our
police officers or other states
attorneys who might be in present um
says that we have essentially red flag
gun confiscation laws in RSA 173 and
633 um and I'm I'm not sure if you're
aware of that again I'm still doing my
own research to understand all the
details here but that um these types of
orders are approved automatically by
judges with with no review and I wasn't
sure if you might have comment on that
um and um also on on some of the online
content that says that there's extremely
high storage fees for those whose guns
have been uh taken so with reference to
Red Flag laws in 173 and
633 633 3A is the stalking statute which
I assume is what they're referring
to saying that these don't get looked at
by a judge a temporary restraining
doesn't get looked at a judge is is just
simply false um there is a standard in
173 B4 in order to obtain a temporary
restraining
order I've never attempted to obtain one
but I've had I've I've been in Circuit
Court almost every day for 17 years and
I've seen people obtain them and I've
seen people have them
denied um I also know from speaking to
members of the the co Coalition and
people from crisis centers who accompany
victims to try and get these hearings
that they're not always granted I know
from speaking to victims in criminal
cases they've indicated I applied for a
temporary restraining order it wasn't
granted so certainly the statement that
you fill out a sheet of paper and this
is automatically granted is is just not
true with reference to the storage fees
again once 73 B5 section 10 C addresses
storage fees it says the law enforcement
agency May charge the defendant a
reasonable fee for the storage of any
firearms and ammunition and specified
deadly weapons taken pursuant to a
protective order the fee shall not
exceed the actual cost incurred by the
law enforcement agency for the storage
of the firearms and ammunition and
specified deadly weapons and then after
that it has the section about the
defendant being being able to make
alternative
Arrangements I've never encountered
storage fees I
presume you could have the situation
where you have a very small Department
that doesn't have a lot of storage and
they seize a very large collection of
firearms and they have to store it
offsite either by renting a storage
locker or by going to a local gun dealer
and having them store it they can pass
that cost a Bel to the defendant but
they
can't this isn't the type of thing where
you can say well our property officer
you know we pay him $50,000 a year to
look at your guns so we're going to
charge you
50,000 it the police can't profit on on
the storage and no up charges and the
and the court protocol addresses that
also and refers back to the to the
when you started your testimony um one
of the things that you uh indic the
reason you indicated you were here was
really for the victims of domestic
violence um should this bill as amended
or as proposed to be Amendment amended
goes through what would be the the
impact do you think on the the number of
homicides the number of court cases that
we see that are more severe are we
talking about
small impact are we talking about a
significant
impact I I think it's hard to answer
that um which I don't I don't have the
statistics at my
fingertips but it's been my experience
and from talking to other people that
women tend to be murdered by people they
know um you know women tend not to be
murdered by Strangers in the Night it
tends to be they're murdered by intimate
partners
and knowing that reality and reading
some of the horrific things we've read
in police reports where people are
subject to domestic
violence
it it it's striking to me
that if we have the
opportunity it this isn't like one of
these things where it's like oh
this random person may hurt me and has
the ability to hurt me this is literally
a person pointing a gun at someone's
head saying I am going to kill you with
this
gun and when that person finally gets to
the point that they seek help from the
state to protect them it seems common
sense to take that gun from that
person thank you I I can comment on that
that article I mentioned I was going to
provide that 2023 article it talks about
that in there and they cite some
statistics and they footnote it within
the article and that's why I want to
submit the article separately they talk
about and I quote from the article more
than half of female homicide victims are
killed by a current or former male
intimate partner and 96% of murder
suicide victims are female Firearms are
used in more than 50% of intimate
partner related
homicides the article goes on to say
about a page or so later a victim or
Survivor of intimate partner violence is
five times more likely to die when an
electronically thank you for your
testimony thank you thank
Shackleford thank you Sergeant good
morning I'll be brief my name is
Katherine shackford I'm a Sergeant with
New Hampshire State Police and I'm here
today representing uh the Department of
Safety Division of State Police in
opposition of this bill I'm not going to
uh reiterate um the information provided
previously so I will say that um I we
absolutely agree with the statements
provided by the Coalition as well as um
the legal the County attorneys that are
here today and feel that this bill um
would prohibit law enforcement from
excuse me working towards ensuring the
safety of victims in the general public
um and it could lead to um increased
homicides in the state of New
Hampshire I would comment on two other
things that have been discussed just
from a state police perspective as well
to state that um it is absolutely the
procedure of New Hampshire State Police
to provide an itemized receipt for all
items um seized um and we do not charge
and I've never heard of State Police
charging um any storage fees I can't
speak towards local law enforcement but
I could state that that um absolutely
comes from State
please thank you for answering those
questions could you just repeat that
what you said about the list I'm sorry
say our procedure to provide an itemized
yes see no further questions thank you
morning is there anyone else present who
wishes to testify who has not testifying
this
bill speak none I hereby close the
public
hearing
and I'm going to open the public hearing
on HB
1073 and invite the sponsor to introduce
his
okay yeah he's
there you called me up for 1073 isct
okay
okay uh good morning chairman uh Roy and
members of the committee I am
representative Sanson naso representing
the towns of ringe Jaffrey and Dublin
House Bill
10733 repeals uh RC
15838 a placement of simulated
explosives it reads any person who
places or cause the placement of a
device simula explosive or other similar
dangerous substance or contrive in any
location
thereby causing anxiety unrest fear or
personal discomfort to any person shall
be guilty of a class a
felony uh the background for the
creation of this bill was uh a
constituent that was threatened with a
felony charge under the statue for
having a gag decoration on their car
during a traffic stop uh the con the
constituent was ordered to remove the
decoration or take the charge he
complied the uh the Law's broad scope uh
results in potential use and unjustified
legal challenges the uh issues with the
current law is uh vagueness and
overreach the law doesn't distinguish
between actual threats to Public Safety
and harmless objects um common gag items
like a uh at auto shops commonly you'll
see a gag with the grenade it says
complaint department pull the pin I
think that would if someone got anxiety
from that they could uh the shop could
be charged with the class a felony
um and
uh so uh hang on I lost my spot sorry uh
found places like our repair shops could
be misconstrued as violations um so
subjectivity and potential misuse a
singles person anxiety irrespective of
context or intent can lead to a felony
charge for example sometimes people have
things like pretend Claymores in yards
um and uh there's a this new business
model called an escape room where you go
into a room and the actual intent is to
cause anxiety uh there could be some
sort of fake explosive there um so I
think that this could be misconstrued to
uh charge those people as well um an
unnecessary legal burden so even if
courts dismiss such cases which I hope
they would uh in instances such as the
constituent case um if it had been
prosecuted the accuse goes uh undergoes
unnecessary legal processes which
themselves are
punitive um so real life implications in
the case of my constituent the result to
remove the gag decaration to avoid a
felony charge highlights the Law's ex
exessive uh scope the this situation
exemplifies the need for legal Clarity
and
fairness um obviously it's not a good
situation when someone uh purposely
causes a panic by placing a simulated
explosive for obvious reasons uh
therefore it's reasonable that the
committee may not want to just outright
delete this um and I think the concerns
could be solved uh by a couple of
amendments uh so to address the concerns
while ensuring Public Safety I suggest
uh following amendments so location
specifity uh private property should be
exempt from the law so you should be
able to put whatever you want on your
own property uh intent so the law should
required demonstratable intent to cause
a panic
uh reasonable standard the law should
consider if it's reasonable for the
situation to cause anxiety and uh impact
threshold uh a felony charge should
require more than one person's
discomfort uh so conclusion I'm ready to
work with the committee to draft
amendment that makes this bill
reasonable and fair makes this law of
reasonable and fair uh ensuring Public
Safety without over criminalizing
innocent Behavior Uh thank you and I
will take questions from the committee
thank you representative um with regard
to to the gag uh thing on your uh
constituents was it a a a trailer hitch
thing that said
Claymore uh I'm not exactly certain of
what the actual uh the device was cuz I
pretty sure I I when I had a pickup
truck I had one it's a it's a trailer
hitch cover that says face towards enemy
I I have seen that exact thing I just
don't know if it was the one the case of
my constituent anyone who's ever
actually used an actual Claymore knows
that they don't look like that at all
and there's much more required to use
okay um thank you see you no further
questions thank you for your testimony
thank
Davy but this this needs to work
morning ladies and gentlemen my name is
Brendan Davy I'm a captain with the New
Hampshire State Police with one month
shy of 23 years of service 16 years in
Patrol uh seven years at headquarters
with Recruitment and training policy and
compliance and now field area uh
Captain the Department of Safety
Division of State Police uh stands in
opposition to this bill uh for the
reason that to
uh to delete a as it sponsor uh has
stated it this provision and its
entirety is to leave public uh the
public at risk to the Spectre which I
submit we increasingly see swatting
calls and uh and hoax devices at the end
of the day I do not disagree uh with the
the bill sponsor that amendments could
be in order uh a felony requires a
culpable mental state and a culpable
mental state ought to be put into this
law uh a reasonable person standard is
built into uh a criminal threatening
statute for example and that could be
built into this law um I would submit
that the uh
improvident decision of one police
officer uh is not reason uh sufficient
to to Warrant deleting uh a law removing
from law prescription on behavior that
in many cases is utterly reasonable in
terms of the response that it uh
provokes and needs to be so uh in the
age of terrorism um from both foreign
and domestic actors and
uh would submit that the the the court
would protect that citizen as they did
in the case of a loaded firearm where
the the law is clear uh and a police
officer misread and misapplied so uh
that concludes my testim ony in this
matter and uh I'd be happy to take
questions thank you um and your your
comments regarding a reasonable person
and certainly intent are well taken I'm
reading a statute it doesn't mention
intent and it seems to me that should be
the the whole point of the statute would
be to with placing something with intent
to cause fear and anxiety not just
simply having something but yes sir any
further questions for the captain seen
none thank you for oh I missed one I
how often do you see something like this
how often does it come up uh in in a an
effort to understand the scope of this
problem just with State Police sir I I
did look up uh for the last calendar
year 2023 the number of uh bomb squad
responses so we get a suspicious package
uh a backpack left somewhere where it it
uh raises the suspicion of of members of
the public and and over that period of
time um I know that our our bomb squad
handles something on the order of 800
calls for service per year many of those
are relinquishments of uh old ordinance
people find uh ammunition in their
basements that belong to family members
who've passed away things of that nature
um so it's difficult to say what the
number of these is I can tell you it is
significant when we get a a suspected
device somewhere um the the scope of the
response that that comes to that when we
have yet to uh determine that it is a
hoax uh is it's of a magnitude that
that's very expensive in terms of all
form of resources and it's very
disruptive to people's lives that said
to
decriminalize what would reasonably
result in that response is is just a bad
idea thank you yes sir representative s
thank you um to follow up on on that um
curious um so if hypothetically there
was a threat here today right now what
would be the um like how does the squad
get activated and then what's the cost
for um dealing with and just you know
identifying either that it's a hoax
device or detonating something because
it can't be determined prior to
detonation whether or not it's a hoax
device um cost is difficult to calculate
ma but um if there were a call in this
building right now um depending on the
quality of the information this whole
place could be cleaned out entirely
disrupted uh staff used to identify to
look for and identify a device uh law
enforcement brought in to manage traffic
and keep people out uh for a certain
blast radius based on the description of
the device itself uh because it's not
direct exposure to device that can kill
people it's compressive blast as well
that will uh will damage um
aquous organs and kill people as well so
it there could be hundreds of police
officers here in in pretty short uh time
and extremely disruptive so many of
those people could be called from other
areas of the state or held out on
overtime or activated from an off-duty
status and so therefore it would be very
expensive but we'd get to go home for
the day is what you're saying yes sir
that was not a suggestion to anyone just
checking all right thank you for your
testimony oh what who oh Stone thank you
and I'll be very quick uh any of the
incidents that your bomb disposed unit
responded to did that involve any
commercially produced items such as the
uh gag gifts such as the dynamite clock
or the trailer hitch Claymore Mine or
the complaint grenade that you probably
have seen yourself over the course of
your career no sir and there again it's
the reasonable person standard on one
side it's a reasonable police officer
standard on the other I I pointed out a
claym a claymore trailer hitch to my
wife the other day see how it says Point
towards enemy so thank you thank you I'm
I'm certain I have one in my garage
because it was on my truck yes sir I
appreciate that we'll work I also may
have a a inner old tank around somewhere
but I mean it's you know yeah
representative
cite i' I'd like you to further comment
on the improvident providential off
Trooper or officer if he saw an incident
that could be arguably considered a
felony a and offered the detainee the
option to remove it I think that sounds
to me very
providential I mean
I not would you want to rethink that
adjective not on the basis of the
characterization of the events sir its
characterization was what was clearly a
gag was uh used as this is going to be
labeled with my initials as exhibit a in
a felony case against you so I I think
it
heavy-handed as described that's all
thank you yes there be no further
questions thank you for your testimony
anyone else wishing to testify on this
bill who is not testified seeing none I
hereby close the public hearing and I
open the public hearing on House Bill
1599 and invite the respons to introduce
this
bill
all right good morning chairman Roy and
members of the committee I am
representative Sant naso representing
the towns of Rin Jaffrey and
Dublin this bill affirms that the second
amendment protects individuals right to
employ weapons capable of making
decisions uh autonomously with the use
of artificial
intelligence the this uh affirmation is
crucial as these kinds of weapons
already exist it's somewhat daunting to
acknowledge our progression into an era
where machines control weapons but
Humanity will adapt to this new reality
as we always
have uh a common image that comes to
mind when discussing AI weapons is
something akin to the Terminator uh
while it's probable that such weapons
will exist uh I want to First highlight
a practical example where this bill will
protect the the public so imagine a
woman being mugged in a parking lot uh
an autonomous car either hers or someone
else's uh is able to detect the
situation and it determines it can
intervene by pushing the mugger away if
allowed to act without human
interference it will do so promptly
otherwise it might require the woman to
press a button to initiate the reaction
uh the action uh however the women may
be physically unable to press the button
or may not realize this as a viable
solution uh if the software can reach
the same conclusion as a reasonable
person would in the same circumstances
then it could be allowed to take the
action without human intervention and we
shouldn't delay these life-saving
measures especially as we move into an
environment filled with autonomous
machines uh we shouldn't say sorry you
got mugged but the government demands
that you first must answer a text
message from your car before these
defense measures measures are put into
action uh furthermore it's reasonable to
imagine that in such situations
artificial intelligence might be better
suited uh to using an appropriate level
of force whereas a person might be
justified in using lethal force with
something like a firearm without the
protective intervention of AI just in
the same way self-driving cars are
expected to cause less accidents than
human drivers um so uh AI can infer the
image of someone looking at it's can
infer the image that someone is looking
at based on just a scan of a brain wave
um so the ACT what what a what AI is
going to be able to infer about what's
going on it's going to be uh oh it's
going to be with perfect Precision uh so
the the world we're moving into with
this stuff is going to be uh so foreign
that in the future in order to describe
the way we live today will only be
possible possible I think in religious
terms uh AI driven weapons have the
potential to offer greater precision and
reduced collateral damage compared to
their human operated counterparts uh
these systems can make rapid
calculations and decisions based on a
multitude of factors aiming to
neutralized threats with minimal harm to
bystanders and
infrastructure this Precision makes the
use of force more ethical and also more
effective and complex real world
scenarios uh a couple other examples uh
that could be a reality like uh today
you'll hear a lot there's stories where
uh High speech police chases going on
and it's stopped by a trucker who saw
the situation and then moved his truck
into that lane uh the suspect is driving
in causing an accident and then
potentially saving lives that could have
been caused if the pursuit was allowed
to continue um so I'm saying that
someone's autonomous car in a parking
lot could you know maybe has assist
police mode turned on by the owner or
something like this and could be alerted
to a similar situation stop the car
because because it's physically
positioned in a strategic location that
benefits the police by chance um and or
maybe five cars could be activated just
block the road the driver's going down
ahead of time um so it's not that you
know I think they're going to outfit
your household toaster with the with the
firearm inside it or something but that
you know it already exists so maybe it
has Intelligence it can detect these
situations and it can maybe uh do
something to mitigate a situation uh
there'll be Hardware all over the place
uh that that we should leverage for our
advantage things like automatically
locking Doors and Rooms until police
arrive that's a use of force decision uh
turning on and off lights uh you know
there's robot vacuums I don't know
people come up with things and they're
very creative um Firearms have been
called the great equalizer where a 5-
Foot Woman armed with a handgun can
defend herself from a significantly more
powerful man uh this is true but it
requires that the women learn and
understand how to use a firearm and stay
current on training learn safety
techniques AI weapons will be even more
so an equalizer to include those who are
unable to wield firearms and are unable
uh unwilling to learn how to use them
and providing safety and defense
capabilities to those who might
otherwise be physically vulnerable like
the elderly or
disabled so a crude version of a weapon
that has the ability to make a uh a use
of force decision has already existed
for centuries uh things like booby traps
and landmines uh so booby traps have
basic they're outlawed by numerous case
law uh example of a booby trap is like a
shotgun with a trigger tied to a door so
such that when the door opens it kills
the person opening it so there's some
binary intelligence there it just kills
whoever opens that particular door so uh
the bill States the decision of
autonomous artificial intelligence is
subject to the same standards as
described in this chapter as if a
natural person made the decision uh if
the decision of the autonomous
artificial intelligence deemed not
Justified on this chapter justification
shall not be available as a defense in
any action or prosecution brought
against the owner or employer of the
artificial intelligence so since it's
unreasonable for a person to make a kill
a decision to kill based solely on a
particular door open uh this sort of
weapon would not be protected by
this AI weapons are here in March of
2020 a quadcopter drone with an
explosive payload in Libya autonomously
hunted down and killed a human Target in
a kamakazi style attack with no human
intervention after deployment Poss
possibly uh being the first time a drone
has been used to autonomously kill a
human uh the thing about these kind of
weapons that are unlike the Terminator
type movies that try to portray such
things is when you see the hero uh
evading the gunfire from the
machine in reality the machine will
never miss the hero will not be running
through gun power it'll have
near-perfect targeting to with the
ability to predict your movements
they'll have a perfect shot every
time uh so without these countermeasures
uh we stand little chance against such
weapons drones are inexpensive and the
software will be if not already ready
readily available and runs on consumer
grade Hardware making regulation to
prevent these weapons futile AI software
requires very powerful computers and
massive amounts of data to create but
once generated can run on consumer grade
Hardware uh for example stable diffus a
stable diffusion model uh encapsulating
a Pera of Artistic Styles cultural
nuances and drawing techniques for a
myriad of artists is compacted in less
than 5 gigabytes it isn't merely data
it's a condensed Universe of human
creativity and intellect uh it's totally
unbelievable that requires so little dis
base and is capable of running on an
ordinary standard off-the-shelf
computer uh and once these models are
generated they are promptly leaked for
the world to use like meta's llama model
which met headlines in March of 2023
after being leaked into a forchan uh a
week after its
Announcement by acknowledging this
existing right uh we may open this
industry up for development in Hampshire
where other jurisdiction's initial
reaction to AI will be an attempt to
limit it hereby making the government in
that area less Revenant relevant as AI
becomes more relevant uh AI will greatly
exacerbate asymmetrical Warfare so
asymmetrical warair is being is things
like uh an American humy with you know
and soldiers getting killed and the in
destroying the Humvee uh with nothing
more than just a single roadside bomb uh
AI will increas greatly increase this
Delta to allow a group with very small
means the capability to destroy major
targets um an example could be a
malicious person or group could spend a
couple hundred bucks to purchase an RC
helicopter or drone from uh Amazon or
Walmart outfit it with a computer and a
bomb and then instruct the computer uh
to Target a particular person using
images obtained online um and then the
helic opter could literally wait for the
Target to exit their house fly up to
them and explode uh this could be done
from hundreds of miles away or even a
sign a sophisticated attack from
elsewhere targeting People based on
ethnicity political affiliation or the
religion the AI could just look at
people and just determine if they're of
one of these groups uh so a defense of
this kind of thing isn't obvious with
conventional means um attempting to
police everyone deploying such weapons
would require a IAL government because
you'd have to ban all sorts of Hardware
Implement extreme tracking on all
purchases and monitor all internet
traffic and monitor all people uh
because the stuff is too it's going to
be too easy to get uh by allowing these
weapons to exist without countermeasures
will also lead to tyranny as governments
and potential hostile entities uh
develop these weapons it's vital that
citizens also have access to comparable
defense Technologies to maintain a
balance of power this parody helps
prevent a scenario where the general
public is left defenseless against a
more technological Advanced threat
whether it come from within or outside
National borders that's why I believe we
should affirm that the second amendment
protects individuals rights to bear arms
for this next generation of weapons uh
thank you and I will take questions from
the
committee thank you representative
um I've for 20 years I've wanted my own
Terminator I just don't know that I
could afford it wouldn't you say this is
regressive and that only rich people
will be able to afford these type of
these things and people of limited means
will not how much would one of these
things cost I would believe any type of
automated um system that would capable
of fire firing a firearm would be very
expensive uh that's true I also I can't
afford uh my own tank I'd like one of
those uh do that authoriz uh that that
would be an expensive that's a
conventional weapon that is available
right now uh so a lot of these weapons I
think will be integrated into existing
Hardware just like my examples with the
autonomous cars this Hardware is going
to be built and it's going to be
autonomous uh there's going to be
machines that do everything like locking
doors automatically and stuff like this
and I'm saying that blocking someone in
a room is a use of force decision uh and
this could be decided
autonomously uh I think better you know
potentially better than a human could
make that decision um and since that
Hardware is there and the software's
already there it's just allowing it to
do these things um and that's why there
should be liability on the owner of the
uh actual
software representative
Pro so that was pretty much my question
I have all this stuff in my car or
wherever and it makes a wrong decision
and kills somebody who's responsible for
that right who's going to jail for that
so just like uh one of the problems with
that with uh self-driving cars is people
like well if the car makes an accident
and kills somebody uh who's responsible
for that um and it's not that an
accident will never happen but accidents
happen today and I would just argue that
there'll be less accidents uh it'll be
that the AI just like in the
self-driving it's going to overall be
better um but who would be responsible
as the owner of the actual
system as it's so if it's my system
and I tell it not to and it still does I
go to jail well uh I'm not exactly sure
how the Market's going to play out on it
but what I would suspect is that you
would have a subscription to it uh I
don't know you know the market could
come up with all sorts of creative
things but I would suspect if you bought
the car the manufacturer of the car
would provide that software um and they
it so we don't really have this
technology to a point that we know what
it is know how proficient it is how
reliable it is and we want to legalize
it is that is that
your premise of this bill just like
today if you uh go ahead and make a use
of force decision that's that's
incorrect right you'd be prosecuted for
that so if you implemented a weapon that
makes a use of force decision that's
wrong you would you would face the same
consequence
um so it's just affirming that this
already
exists representative um
new thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question um I just you you
mentioned you know you're talking about
um autonomous cars and um also you know
the facial recognition and um I'm just
wondering have you heard about the many
stories of autonomous vehicles um uh
going AR and causing accidents that that
even the operator cannot stop um cars
that are being recalled exactly for that
reason also um the Discrimination that
is built into the bias that is built
into facial recognition this has been
shown demonstrated time and time again
and um you know the thing being that an
algorithm is still informed by people um
and still can be uh misinformed and
reflect the biases of the people who
create that algorithm and I'm just
curious are you aware of that and are
you concerned about that with with
technology like this um used for
um defense in and things like
that uh yes of course but uh human
operators have biases as well uh and I
think that the AI you know it's the
responsibility is still on the is still
on the owner just as if the AI makes an
erroneous decision uh it would be on the
already
representative
Newman thank you um I'll just call your
attention to the on Guess on page two
that the line that begins on 23 that
says if the decision of the aut
autonomous artificial intelligence is
deemed not justified under this
chapter justification shall not be
available as a defense in any action of
prosecution brought against the owner or
employer of the artificial
intelligence could you just point me to
anything in the bill in the if I don't
think there's an amendment to the bill
or anywhere else in this chapter where
it defines who makes that decision since
this is a new a whole new thing about
artificial
intelligence uh yeah if it's not
outlined correctly we can uh fix it um
it's if the Bill's not totally complete
then we can work on
that thank
you
Reed thank you Mr chairman this is a
frightening New Era and I'm really
outside of my my scope of expertise but
would this be hackable could China or
one of our enemies hack into these these
um AI things and cause
harm so thank you yes it's actually
particularly my worry that these uh
there's going to be atom machines all
over the place that could be hacked um
but the problem is I I would rather live
in the 20th century but these these
machines are going to be they're going
to exist they already exist there's
already cars that are built today are
fly by wire you're communicating with a
computer when you control the steering
wheel it doesn't have a steering shaft
um and right now somebody could put
software on those vehicles and make it
do something erroneous uh so this is in
my opinion a way to protect against
those kind of things
um
representa thank you Mr chairman thank
you for taking my question I Echo what
representative Reed just said it's I
felt like we were in science and
technology there for a second this is a
little bit out of my scope um but I also
uh My worry is that these Technologies
are uh I
mean are they're really self-defense or
assist police Technologies built into uh
the Tesla cars or I mean what is the
reality of uh of what these devices are
what they can do uh I'm just trying to
get an idea of what the AI device would
be and how it would be used as defense
would people just be able to have these
military-grade
quadcopters that were out in Libya or or
are we talking about uh cars that are
able
to move to one lane or the other to stop
a an accident or something like
that
so uh things like these quadcopter
things that in limbya that example I
used I just I believe that they're going
to be way too cheap to produce uh so
anybody could make these right now I
think you could just go spend less than
probably $1,000 and build something
comparable to what hunted down that
person in 2020 um so because the threat
is there I think we should not prohibit
uh people from using the same kind of
themselves and to answer your question
um they are capable of programming all
kinds of things into cars if if the
government mandated it they could
program a kill switch into most cars
that the police would just be able to
shut it off I have seen that um
representative Muse and then
representative
PE if you see this technology as being
such a problem why doesn't your bill
just make it
illegal uh the reason why is because I
don't believe that's it's possible I
think that by making it illegal it the
only way you could carry it out by
having an extreme tyan uh tyrannical
government because the I mean what does
it cost to buy one a drone I mean they
cost nothing and bombs and these the
software is readily available uh they
can't protect the software and it runs
on a regular a regular GPU can you can
run these Advanced AI uh you know uh
what do they call them like large
language models and the neural networks
and stuff and have it create artwork and
come up with it can write entire uh
books you know on on on Hardware that's
uh cheap so to prohibit people from
having that is it's impossible it's too
easy to
construct thank
you representative
PR are you aware that arm drones are
already legal in the
state uh if they're illegal or not legal
it's you could just buy one I understand
that they're specifically um mentioned
as illegal for use in um surveilling or
chasing game by um by taking of game uh
see no further questions thank you for
your testimony thank you and the chair
again
thank you ladies and
gentlemen again I'm captain Brendan Davy
with New Hampshire State Police uh just
short of 23 years of service and uh 15
and a half of those on our SWAT team uh
I've seen a YouTube video of a
quadcopter with a Glock pistol attached
to it um it's one of the more
frightening things I've ever seen
despite the the real things that I've
seen that are quite frightening um I
would submit to you that many of the
sponsors responses to your questions
were indicative of his hesitation to uh
trust this technology and uh the
department of
safety's uh standpoint and and view on
this legislation uh is uh in keeping
with those hesitations and we oppose it
anything that removes the direct sense
of ownership agency and therefore
culpability in any use of
force is not something that uh the state
police would Embrace because it makes
more difficult to uh hold to account the
actions that resulted in death or
serious bodily injury or deprivation of
right in any other way uh and so uh we
we oppose the bill um with regard to uh
the use of AI I would submit to you that
that Genie is already out of the bottle
my understanding is that any system that
has AI um that the mere inclusion of a
few new lines of code is what can make
an autonomous system system uh or make a
a uh an intelligent system to Anye any
degree
autonomous uh while I would agree that
artificial intelligence well used very
welld designed extremely robustly tested
uh can outperform Humanity in certain
tasks uh Israeli defense mechanisms as
they exist right now can identify an
incoming rocket in one millisecond where
the human being is capable only of
perceiving it at about 250 milliseconds
and then limited further in its response
time uh artificial intelligence is not
prone to emotion it is not prone to
fatigue those are certainly advantages
that can and will be uh made use of at
some point in the future uh as of right
now if someone flew that drone with a
Glock on it in New Hampshire and used it
to do harm to someone State Police would
still have a case on our hands and the
Attorney General's office would expect
us to investigate prove ownership prove
agency prove culpability and uh and
secure a conviction if at all possible I
would submit that uh the main examples
of the use of artificial intelligence
for autonomous delivery of any uh
methodology of force outside of this
this one uh Glock on a on a quadcopter
are military and therefore Elon Musk and
his ilk are the only people likely to be
able to employ these things with any uh
significant effect um the uh the use of
AI in military uh situations is under
intense scrutiny and at the same time
that is recognize that there is an arms
race that the country uh or state that
develops these best and first and most
readily will probably trouts those who
Trail um there are also serious ethical
concerns that have been spoken to a bit
here today so for all the reasons for
going uh State Police and Department of
Safety would oppose this
legislation thank you k Captain to the
best of your knowledge is there not
currently available um for a significant
expense but available firearms that have
a certain level of AI in them in that
they adjust for windage automatically um
depending on the round in the distance
um they actually adjust they're called
smart rifles um some of them even be
online of sight yes sir I've read that
there are such things there there are uh
some computer uh some computer guiding
systems that do assist with Munitions as
I understand as
well thank you representative
jamron thank you Mr chairman and thank
you for taking my
question uh we we've already established
that set guns are illegal and that
police officers and Firearms defense
experts who engage in shoot don't shoot
situations don't always agree on if they
got it right which leads to
litigation um do you believe that a AI
can take the place of a human brain at
this point to make those
decisions at this point sir no and
followup thank you Mr chairman do you
believe that the human brain can make
mistakes absolutely sir thank you yes
sir represent wheeler thank you Mr
chairman and thank you for taking my
question um so if someone were to use a
quadcopter commit murder and the
department of safety only saw the quad
opter was able to get it down how would
you prosecute that person who launched
that drone if there was a way to do that
yes sir uh we'd have to determine
ownership control uh and work our way
back to the person who who had conducted
um that act through technology and that
would clearly be a much more difficult
thing than a person with a gun in his
hand thank you yes
sir representative Newman I
see yeah I just have uh question that
deals with the last comment um if if I
had my 9 millimeter set up somewhere
automatically withd draw in wait a
minute did you just Adit you have a 9 mm
what what did I say
um I don't remember what I said oh do I
live for your die sir go ahead let me uh
restate that if a person had a 9
mm and the and they had artificial
intelligence at their disposal and they
could activate the artificial
intelligence to to immediately draw the
gun and shoot in a at whatever is they
deemed to be threatening
them do you see a difference between
that whether I pull the trigger or or
whether that person pulls the trigger or
whether they activate the artificial
intelligence to do that how how would
that work in the
situation it's a difficult question to
answer but at the end of the day uh what
I would uh speculate here that at trial
you're going to say that it was the AI
that made the bad decision and not you
the problem with that is it's still all
yours um and that makes securing a
conviction for what ultimately really
what ultimately would result in perhaps
an unjustified loss of life still your
responsibility just a lot more difficult
to
prove I have a question to the chair can
I can I just make a comment about
something thing that I've air traffic
control and automation that may be
relevant to what we're talking about and
my comment would be that air traffic
control I worked in that for many years
both as one and trying to automate one
they've been trying to automate it for
since
1985 and the thing is the human is still
responsible for separating the aircraft
no matter what they are using to
separate the aircraft so the
responsibility in my opinion comes back
to the owner
when they activate or use that and
they're the ones responsible for doing
that thank you thank you for sharing
that I I I agree it goes back to
Theology of the prime mover whoever set
it in motion is the one who is
responsible representative of
scitec it sounds like your opposition is
or your your position is not yet on this
bill that's a that's well said sir uh I
I have yet spoken the yet to speak the
word premature but the the division
would would see this as
that see no further questions thank you
for your testimony is there anyone else
wishing to testify in this bill who has
not yet testified seeing none I hearby
left yeah we're behind 10 minutes I open
the public hearing on HB
1237 and we're going to take a 15minute
bar
break
at this point I'm opening a public
hearing on hit
1237 uh a little departure from normal
um a house bill 1237 1238 very closely
related the sponsors requested to speak
to them both at the same time so I'm
going to let him introduce them both at
the same time so keep in mind we're
talking about both bills in the interest
of time thank you go ahead all right
thank you to to the uh the chairman of
the committee and and the the members of
the committee
I'm
um pardon me Brandon finny straford 9
which is Rochester Ward 6 I'm here to
introduce uh hb1 1237 NH hb12 38 which
are um about unmarked police vehicles
and applying Municipal Police plates to
said police vehicles um I want to keep
it as concise as I can in and you know
on the interest of time and your
attention um I want to harp on a couple
of things um so essentially what these
bills are pertaining to is only
Municipal police departments I've
excluded the State Police from the scope
of the bills um to allow them more more
flexibility in their operations so I'm
only talking about Municipal um local
police departments who would conduct any
type of traffic enforcement um
only um you know speeding um stop lights
that you know that kind of thing we're
not talking about undercover
investigations or any or any other type
of criminal um investigations it's only
about uh the enforcement of of um
vehicle St uh
statutes um so the first thing I want to
I want to harp on is uh the idea of
Public
Safety um currently the way that the
police operates um based on a 2005
Supreme Court
uh Castle Rock against uh uh Gonzalez um
this the the institution of policing is
not under any type of constitutional
requirement to um um protect or serve
which is what we've all come to
understand what what what the role of
police in our society is to do
um in that case their tactics have
changed as far as how they enforce the
law on the road and also how they tend
to generate some revenue for the state
um and the idea of not allowing unmarked
police vehicles for the sake of of um
enforcing uh traffic laws and also uh
having the uh requirement to have
Municipal Police plates on the vehicle
is so that everyone on thead can clearly
see that that there is an officer on the
road who's conducting speed trap um
speed trap operations either um on the
public road even on some sections of
Highway um the the the goal here is to
make sure that all the vehicles that
that are on the road that are used to
pull people over for you know for
infractions um have police on the
vehicle that we can see what department
it's from that it is um
you you know I'm an official Public
Service vehicle um this this the stealth
vehicles that don't have plates on them
we don't always know if they're police
officers or not and while uh there are a
lot of policies from departments in New
Hampshire and and outside of New
Hampshire that require officers to State
who they are um who they are and where
they're from U it doesn't stop people
from personing police officers that's
what we want to avoid here um
another um aspect of this for
accountability um you know we want our
police officers to conduct themselves
you know professionally and also to
respect the rights of people um in their
vehicle on the road um their rights are
always
Paramount so we want to we want to have
accountability for for police officers
that that go a little above and beyond
with how they enforce some of the
traffic laws and and um a large issue
that I think a lot of you have seen is
is um you know some departments Who hide
a lot of their you know their vehicles
off the road you can't see them from the
road they don't have any
reflective um like you know you know the
lettering and emblems on the side of it
so you don't see it's there you got to
give um people a time to comply if they
see a police officer they can slow down
or or if uh you know they were going to
run a yellow light that that may have
turned red they would stop because
they'd see a police officer and that
would you know that might um actually
prevent a fatal accident which um I
don't know if you guys have have seen
but the rates of traffic accidents um
and fatalities in New Hampshire has gone
up it's gone up significantly it's not
just based on this issue um there's a
whole host of issues as to why um we've
are are having more traffic um accidents
in New Hampshire but um the the goal
here is to make sure that everyone's
complying on the road with the
established you know um uh road laws
pardon me for my uh speech impediment um
one one main issue that I that I'd like
to harp on is that we still have civil
asset civil asset for forfeiture in New
Hampshire which would allow police
departments to seize and then repurpose
um whatever they get from people to then
use on the road to to to stop people
with and I think that is a practice in
New Hampshire that we should not allow U
I think every officer who would conduct
those operations on the road should be
clearly marked and and and and um and
identified so that we trust that the
person that that we're interacting with
is who they say that they
are um and that we don't run into any
escalation
um so that's the the the section on the
vehicles on themselves
um I made the date for after the next
year um so that any Department in New
Hampshire that would have an
unmarked um an unmarked vehicle that
they would use to to enforce uh Road
road traffic laws um to you know the
ability to to be you know be ready with
either funding or to get rid of the
vehicle that they would not be able to
use if if you know if this bill was to
go through and that they would also be
in compliance with the statute um I I
made the additional bill um to have
Municipal Police uh plates on the
vehicle in case this bill did not pass
we would still have a fail save to at
least have an identifying Mark and any
of the the the department vehicles that
you know that they would then use on the
road we we all know what the state
police vehicles look like even if
they're not marked we see how they're
how they're fixed we can see the the
state police plates on them but not a
lot of local police departments have
that requirement or or policy um built
in and and they use that for various um
uh uh stealth practices that that I
think uh could be in violation of the
um the last thing I wanted to bring up
is that I think that if we were um to
codify in the statute that all all
Municipal police departments must be
clearly marked that that would Foster
more trust um in the in the institution
of of policing in New Hampshire where we
may not see a lot of the problems that a
lot of the bigger states do but but we
can at least say in New Hampshire that
that that we do uh respect you know the
rights and privacy of people um to to
you know to travel without being
harassed and um you know to also travel
and and have the the the the knowledge
that uh that they're going to be pulled
over by somebody who has a flashing blue
light on their vehicle that they are who
they say that they are um anybody can
buy a
surplus um or otherwise uh de uh
decommissioned you know uh police
vehicle through auction or just you know
from a local uh Used Car Sale place and
that person doesn't have the the um
illegality of being able to buy uh buy
certain types of equipment that that
they could then put on their vehicle and
illegally harass people on the road as a
non-p police officer so it's you know
accountability for those people uh where
it's already illegal to personate a
police officers so we' be able to easily
convict that person but also more
accountability for the police um that we
can clearly see who they are um that
that they identify with uh the the
department that's hiring them to conduct
those operations but I also want to
stress again that these two bills don't
have anything to do um with operations
that are outside of enforcing road laws
so that if if any police officer was to
come up here to oppose the bill um
special um like U
um special investigations are not in the
scope of the bill it's only what you see
out on the road so
um that being said I'll take any
questions thank you I'm looking at the
license plate bill um
first each Municipal Police Department
shall fix M Municipal Police license
plates on Department owned Vehicles no
officer shall use any vehicle that does
not bear Municipal Police license plates
for the performance of official duties
that does not limit it to traffic so for
Undercover purposes often times police
will use a a a normal license plate um
and often times if you run that plate it
comes back to nobody because
sometimes especially when you get into
higher level drug investigations the
cartels and people actually have people
that work in dispatch and things like
that will run plates for for those
people so that the plate comes back to
no one is it your intent that this
should only limit traffic to traffic
enforcement for the plates or for all
the Municipal Police Vehicles ideally it
would be for traffic only um but I do
think philosophically that if a police
department would would would buy a
vehicle for any type of operation
whether it's for special investigations
or otherwise that the vehicle should be
identified as
such even under cover
operations and well in that case no but
but the scope is for traffic okay gotcha
um representative
Newell thank you Mr chair and thank you
for taking my question um I actually
have an experience with uh being pulled
over by someone who I am still not sure
if they were actually a police officer
on a desolate Montana highway uh and had
to pay for a ticket immediately um right
there they're going to I don't know I
still don't know if this is um a real
police officer or not but um anyway
fortunately that was not in this state
but I understand what it's like to be
pulled over and wonder um so this bill
seems seems pretty um good for for uh
addressing that in that moment so my
question to you is sorry it's taking me
a bit to get there the question is um
would there be uh the important part
about that for from my perspective would
be so that people understand and can
identify themselves if they're being
pulled over whether this is um actually
a police officer or not and so my
question is would this be accompanied by
um education for people uh particularly
people who may uh likely be V uh
victimized or targeted such as uh a
single driving down the street at a
desolate Highway in Montana absolutely I
think more more people in the public
should be aware um not only of of the
traffic laws but also um some department
policies they should be in tune with
what the policy um or what their you
know department is doing with with the
powers that they have um and in that
instance um you know I I totally
sympathize with the the plight of a lot
of the women um who
you know would encounter that because we
we've seen in the news of assaults and
you know know those robberies and stuff
that had taken place while by a police
officer or not um that this is just one
part of some uh uh uh reform that that I
figured would would be easily you know
easily amendable to to even a lot of the
more staunch police departments that say
like well you know we should identify we
should be clearly marked so people can
you know can see who we are and you know
you know so that we can place our TR you
know
our we can place our trust in them
again thank you representative s thank
you um my question is related I think to
Chairman Roy um so with the license
plates and the mandatory marking of
Municipal vehicles I think about our
detectives who often need to be in
surveillance vehicles that don't have
marking specifically for the purposes of
doing appropriate detective work and
safety work but they also if
they're not in the process or maybe even
while they're in the process of doing
their
detectiving whatever the terminology
would be for that um if they see for
example someone who is driving who
appears obviously impaired um or perhaps
someone driving down Main Street and
Durham going 100 miles an hour on a 25 M
hour Zone they have the ability to then
stop that vehicle because it's a safety
issue right and and appropriate for them
to
make that determination and I'm sure
Chief Dean can attest to that as well
but so this requiring them to have
Municipal Vehicles would make it so they
wouldn't be able to do their detective
work and with I'm trying to figure out
how to make it work and so perhaps you
have an idea of how they can maintain
their need to be in an undercover
surveillance mode while also having a
municipal license plate that identifies
them as a police officer which would
negate their ability to be in
surveillance I don't think in every
instance a detective has to be
undercover for them to perform what you
know whatever um operations on their
case that that they need to do um I was
more thinking of of actual um you know
the the the U patrol cars that we see
every day um obviously like I know that
we have to have undercover operations
for you know you know for certain types
of cases um I did read that there are
some states that um do allow you know
the the pulling over uh with an unmarked
police U police vehicle but they're also
required to call for a you know a
uniformed um patrol unit to come um um
assist with that stop I I I think with
with how small some of our departments
are how small some of our towns are I
don't think it's it would be out of the
ordinary for you know for them to to do
to representative
Stone thank you Mr chair and thank you
for taking my question
if this bill was to pass wouldn't we be
impeding on local control each
municipality obviously has a governing
body that sets a budget and allows for
vehicles to be purchased and by doing
that it gives the discretion to the
local agency if they want to have what
type of vehicles they want to have and
what kind of use they want to do and as
well as establishing their own policies
do you feel that we'd be kind of
treading on that if uh we were to pass
something like this and limiting their
control on what they can purchase and
how they can utilize it since each
municipality is uniquely different
whether you're in clamont Manchester or
ctie or in your own Hometown um I think
in the case where police departments are
receiving um you know taxpayer funded
items or equipment um there should be
accountability from the state as well I
understand what you're saying um but
we're not we're not seeing that kind of
accountability on the local um you know
like on the level where they would um
voluntarily be willing to um be clearly
marked and you know you know identified
for the public they they would choose to
rather hide on you know on the side of
the road and not give people time to
comply with whatever they're that that
that that they be stopping for um I
believe that we have the right in the
purview to um keep our police our you
know police departments accountable also
with with the state but not just with
the
taxpayers so basically this bill aims at
uh a slang called a road pirate is
trying to you know C of that type of
behavior is what the bill is intended
for essentially yes thank
you represent chairman again Mr chairman
thank you for taking my question it's
actually twofold so I'll probably ask
for a
followup uh on both bills I've noticed
that you are using the verbiage of any
Municipal police vehicle now to me that
means a local police department which in
essence is that you're you're
intent in your bills to exempt the state
police the sheriff and his deputies
constables fish and game and liquor
enforcement I mentioned that in the
beginning um that I didn't include the
the State Police in this purview um you
know for that purpose that they um some
of their Highway operations require some
you know some of their practices but um
I didn't include the state police on
purpose and to
followup um also uh this specifically to
House Bill
1238 where you are saying that if they
don't have a municipal license plate
they cannot be used for police
purposes that would basically prohibit a
police officer who is operating on
traffic enforcement detail to not use
his personally owned vehicle is that
you no I don't I I don't know that
that's what you mean
mean if a if a traffic if an officer is
doing a detail he's he's just there
standing outside you know uh directing
traffic and he's brought his own vehicle
um he's not you don't intend that he
can't bring his own vehicle to the
detail is that what you're saying I'm
saying that he should be in a clearly
okay um who's left
am
yeah thank you and thank you for taking
a question and this has going to piggy
back on representative janin so this
does not apply to Sheriff's Vehicles
constables fishing game as well correct
just local police okay correct thank you
y representative Pratt sure do you
believe there's a value for police
presence and visibility in a community
to deter
crime I'm sorry say it again do you
believe there is a value for police
presence and visibility in a community
to deter a crime
100%
represent wheeler thank you Mr chairman
thank you for taking my question do you
believe that sorry are there any states
that have prohibited uh unmarked
vehicles from being used in traffic law
enforcement and as a second part to that
question do you think that there would
be any instance in which uh unmarked
Vehicles would be good to use in in
traffic law
enforcement um good to
use in my view no um I don't but there
are not that many states know that have
um outlawed a prohibited um I'm I'm I'm
just like in its entirety there they
have some you know some some
stipulations there where where they
could still do that but you know there's
always like you know you can do this but
um and there and there are some states
like here in New Hampshire we don't have
any you know stipulations on on how
they're able to conduct their on
laws what would those other states be
that have not full prohibitions but like
you said sort of half you can do this
plan you know I should have that
information I I apologize for not having
that up top of my head I but I but I can
get that to you thank you
yeah see no further questions thank you
guys
thank you ladies and gentlemen I'll be
brief uh appreciate the car out for the
New Hampshire State Police in this
especially that given that I drive a an
unmarked black charger um with a
passenger plate the record for which
does come back to the Department of
Safety State Police I I'll do my best
ma'am to avoid you in the future but uh
42 miles uh between my house and
headquarters um classified more as a
commuter than as a cop these days and
yet I I make stops every day I I uh do
take pleasure in being the answer to the
question where's a cop when you need one
uh at least a handful of times a year uh
I would argue that the the goal of the
law first is is voluntary compliance
whether a cruiser is present and within
view is uh in my experience and uh much
to my shock in many cases not a material
fact in the decision-making process of
many a driver um that said
accountability is an important thing
uniform is an important thing State
Police uses our Mark plates when we're
out on on patrols uh in an age where a
mere 7% of serving police officers some
10,000 who answered a survey from
caliber press uh in 2020 7% said that
they would Rec uh recommend law
enforcement to people within their
families people within their spheres of
influence as a career um we suffer an
unprecedented uh lack of police officers
out there and and some of those people
are assigned to detective uh assignments
and undercover assignments and of course
for undercover just makes good sense not
to be applicable to them but every
holiday you'll see a lot of blue lights
out on interstates in particular but
small roads as well I come from a rural
troop I am the community police I grew
up being the the community police in
that in that area and uh when I go out
on patrol it's in those small areas and
so unmarked police cars are utilized by
those employees to supplement the patrol
numbers and to have effect to to keep
the public safe on the days where we
expect higher traffic um I'm sure
Municipal agencies have uh I know that
they do have uh similar situations for
themselves and and would support them
and their ability still to do that uh
with regard to the question sir on what
states uh Outlaw or allow the use of
unmarked Cruisers uh I'm a son of a
state trooper I remember my father
talking about um Rhode Island in
Connecticut K State Police and I can't
remember which of the two was Notorious
for actually using private Vehicles it
was a Ford F-150 it was a Camaro but um
in the case where any unmarked vehicles
are used uh and forgive me for not
knowing specifically given that my
computer just died but uh it was one of
the two um allows for the use of
unmarked Vehicles provided that the
driver is in full uniform um that said I
think it's still reasonable um within
our state to expect police officers to
be able to identify themselves well the
use of bodyw War cameras and the
proliferation of other um accountability
measures have all been set to advance um
our accountability to the public our our
requirement that we conduct ourselves
with professionalism no matter what it
is that we're driving that's all I'll
have goe thank you Mr chairman Captain
Dave I just want to apologize I wasn't
um I wasn't asking you to hurry up I was
being sarcastic and saying can you give
us more information on the vehicle and I
think that that might have been confused
and I apologize if you think I was being
disrespectful to I was making a joke
actually thank you not at
all representative Jamon thank you Mr
chairman um and thank you for taking my
question um I'm looking at House Bill
1237 which is the one uh that would
prohibit them from being used for
performing traffic law enforcement could
you explain to me if the driving Under
the Influence or driving while
intoxicated laws are considered La uh
traffic traffic law enforcement I would
consider them to be so sir because
they're within the motor vehicle manual
followup so if this bill were to pass as
written presently uh a police officer in
an unmarked car could not make a motor
vehicle stop for DWI a suspected DWI is
that correct yes sir if if that were the
interpretation yeah yes you're
Balden thanks for taking my question um
are you aware of
any studies or in
statistics related to whether the
visible presence of a marked police car
um affects behavior and if you're
unaware Do you have a perspective on
that absolutely Ma I have uh 22 years of
experience of watching people behave
exceedingly well uh while my marked
Cruiser was within their presence um
I've seen it change Behavior markedly
instantaneously upon the apparent
apprehension of drivers that they're in
the presence of a New Hampshire state
trooper um and I have seen um just the
the slightest and and most brief show of
lights for example or the recognition by
someone that I've got lights within the
the vehicle that I drive now um
significantly change Behavior so yes
ma'am
follow so is it possible that marking
more police vehicles that are on the
road could reduce instances of criminal
Behavior or
violations uh there's no question in my
mind that um more marked police vehicles
throughout the world would likely have a
desirable effect on on driving behavior
it would probably help people to drive
more
safely yes
ma'am representative
Newman I was going to ask you about the
blue lights but your your vehicle does
have that um what happens if a police
officer if you were just commuting in
your own car to work and there was some
kind of traffic violations would what
happens then do you do anything does
that have
any
I don't as a practice um do work in a
personal vehicle I have been involved
over the course of my career in a
handful of enforcement actions in really
really dangerous situations that
required me to take action even though I
was not on duty and not even in in
uniform um I don't know if that's
responsive enough sir just follow up the
policy of the State Police is not for
its members to conduct traffic um
traffic inter ition while off duty or
out of uniform is it it's uh it's
strongly discouraged sir because it's a
it's an invitation to what looks may
look more like a road rage incident than
a a a law enforcement action thank you
followup
represent okay um representative
Manion thank you and thank you for
taking my question this is going to
piggy back off uh representative
balin's statement a question about
marked Vehicles clearly have a more more
more of an impact on people's behavior
MH however do you feel that the need for
these ghost Vehicles which are still
marked however it's subtle still visible
when lights hit them and stuff do you
feel that there's still a need for that
type of enforcement in
traffic I do from a traffic safety
standpoint I'm actually a fan of
unmarked Vehicles provided the other uh
aspects of appropriate professional
well-marked easily identified law
enforcement officers are in place um and
and to the to the uh representative
new's comment uh with regard to having
been pulled over by a possible
impersonator I can say that the scope of
that problem as far as New Hampshire law
enforcement is concerned to my
recollection I can
remember two within the last year or so
uh both of whom got figured out and uh
and snared up relatively quickly so the
scope of that is uh not severe to my
knowledge in New Hampshire thank God and
represent Newman I I have a quick
question just about in the situation
that representative new mentioned what
what should a person do when a vehicle
comes up behind them on a dark night and
when and they have blue lights sir and
stops them but there's a concern
about what to do in that situation what
should a person do in that situation um
I'm a parent of five three of whom are
young ladies who all drive and uh my
instructions to them would be call 911
get to a welded area um get to a a
public area where there's high traffic
uh go ahead and turn your turn signal on
so it doesn't appear to be you know an
intention to flee necessarily but have
those Protections in place and if the
person standing at your window doesn't
pass the smell test um can't identify
himself show credentials without the
window rolled all the way down Etc then
you have other decisions to make that
would be really terrible follow
would you consider telling your daughter
to put the flashers on the both the
emergency flashes on instead of the turn
signal oh I consider it
sure well I I appreciate the ask a cop
session we are we are running late so um
please keep your questions to the bill
representative
s
okay any further questions
representative
scite are blue lights illegal for uh
can only Police use blue lights yes sir
okay I've issued SES for that represent
wheeler very quick Mr chairman thank you
how long have unmarked Vehicles been
used in police work this bill uh within
the real of detectives decades uh for
multi-purpose vehicles within the state
police anyway we're approaching 15 years
or so about 15 years for traffic stops
for unmarked Vehicles yes sir okay thank
you yes sir see no further questions
thank you thank you the chair calls uh
Elliot
axelman hi um Ellie axelman from hookset
representing myself um I think on 1237
and 1238 um the the main thing I would
say
is police using unmarked cars or having
license plates that don't denote them as
police um for for regular traffic off is
is not appropriate it's not a kind of
policy that I would want in my state um
I think the the few the little bit I
heard from the previous gentleman
speaking I suppose in opposition to the
bill was I caught something about only
7% of police officers or their family
would recommend the job because the the
overall support for them is not very
high right now I would say I'm not sure
you know what exactly the point of that
was I didn't hear the whole uh context
but I think that when you're pulled over
by an unmarked car or the the
black-on-black police like we have in my
town where where it's essentially
impossible to see the police um that
makes people not love police a lot when
they're undercover and they pull you
over like I was pulled over um at the bo
conquered border a few weeks ago by I
think uh bo police and he said I noticed
as you were driving I saw your
inspection sticker was the wrong caller
it's from last year um sorry so like so
that I I was pulled door for that said
hey it just expired it was my birthday
I'll get it fixed um so I got a warning
but it's stuff like that every time
there's a traffic stop I think one of
the few things that all the sides agree
on right left police anarchists um
traffic stops are inherently dangerous
for so many reasons people can get hurt
um the police officers on the side of
the road especially on a highway if one
driver is texting or coughs or sneezes
or looks down and they swerve off one
inch they can clip the officer and now
we have someone else is dead someone
else going to jail so someone else going
to jail we have orphans and widows and
and he it was one cop pulling over one
guy for an inspection sticker and now we
have widows and and you know kids
without par it's very sad and the risk
reward in my opinion is not really worth
it someone with uh an expired inspection
sticker um you know probably would have
survived and and uh now we have people
dead so so police officers pulling
people over it's dangerous for them it's
dangerous for me I I carry 247 if you
say the GW the cop you know very often
will get a and they'll pull out their
gun and maybe kill you so we've seen a
lot of those videos too um where
anything wrong can happen where if he
says wear your hands get your
registration move your hand the wrong
way people people can get hurt so every
traffic stop there's there's inherent
risks and everyone agrees on that
there's risks to everyone the the driver
the police officer other pedestrians
drivers and others in the car so if we
could I would say eliminate pretty much
all traffic stops unless there's a clear
and imminent danger of someone swerving
or driving 150 something like that
routine traffic tops for like very much
victimless nonviolent offenses um which
happens in New Hampshire cuz New
Hampshire is unique in that I don't know
if other states have uh uh absolute
primary offense so technically every
single thing in the universe that's on
the inspection list which is like 35,000
words is a primary offense so if your
tail light the light bulb on your
license plate shining on it is not good
enough that could be a primary offense
and cops could pull you over and you
fail inspection and the inspection
people tell you they can't pass you if
you have any tiny uh even one little
frame or one molecule covering your
license plate front or back so there are
a lot of little things that are primary
offenses cops can pull you over if you
have anything obstructing either front
or back license plate that has to be
100% clear not one molecule can be
blocking it um so it's things like that
you can get pulled over a lot and I
would say um anytime we can diminish the
amount of traffic stops there are we can
save so much uh risk to police officers
and others and resentment towards
officers because they pull you over and
I don't know a lot of people who like
himer um and and I'm happy to take
questions in a second um and and the
other thing is the waste of productivity
the time is money when I'm pulled over
that's the cop who's being paid by by
taxes and me sitting on the road for 10
20 30 minutes idling my car polluting
the environment with a collective you
know billion tons of CO2 over year um
and we're all wasting a lot of time and
energy and I'm missing time with my son
because I'm on the side of the road
talking about inspection stickers so I'm
happy to take
questions rep readed thank you Mr
chairman so when your precious Sun grows
up and gets his license and has a little
bit of testosterone poisoning and just
lets it rip you know and wraps himself
around a tree I think at one point maybe
a traffic stop you would have wanted
that traffic stop
before Y how do you feel about that yeah
that's a great question so um for a bit
of background I'm as anti-p speeding and
reckless driving as anyone I worked I'm
a paramedic I've worked in EMS since
2011 so I I've seen the really really
bad NBAs and um I'm obviously a
proponent of safe driving I've taught
safety driving for ambulances and
regular cars for a while um and that's
why I drive very conservative especially
with my in the car I drive very slow and
careful um I I would say the one traffic
stop that's legitimate Is For Real
reckless driving so if you if you were
18 and you had testosterone you were
driving way too fast or in a way that is
reckless and and we already have a crime
of reckless driving and any cop that can
all tell you it's it's arbitrary any cop
can pull anyone over for reckless
driving which is you know pretty broad
if they think they driving too fast for
the conditions or the road regardless of
speed limit if they think you're driving
if it's raining and you're driving 35
into 30 like they can pull you over if
you're driving back spe and and I'm I'm
not that opposed to that because if
you're driving really recklessly like if
they say in their affidavit they believe
within a minute someone was going to get
hurt because you were driving so
recklessly they could pull you over but
inspection stickers my license plate
light bulb that shines my plate not
being bright enough or being out or
things like that um like I can't support
those kinds of traffic laws especially
with an unmarked car that's that you
can't see so thank you thank you and
thank you for your testimony thank you
very
much um the chair recognizes The
Reed thank you Mr chair and thank you
honorable members it's a pleasure to be
before you once again I think I'll be
before you again before this year is
out um for the record my name is Ellen
Reed I represent new market and new
Fields Rockingham 10 I will speak
conceptually on the bill I am aware um
that the bill May benefit from
amendments including an amendment uh
potential amendment to um exclude
officers who see Reckless behaviors
while performing other duties like
undercover detective work um I ask that
the committee engage in the good work of
taking the matter seriously and working
on language that would be suitable for
the state um I did want to bring up
before I bring up my I have a personal
story that only happened a month ago um
with regards to being pulled over by an
officer uh not in a marked vehicle but
before I I give you that story I did
want to address a couple things um
representative janen brought up the
issue of uh local control as a Dylan's
rules State we already impede local
control pretty severely we actually
impede all Municipal decisions unless we
actively enable them I actually prefer
uh home rule myself but there is a
reason even in home rule there is a
balance between a higher level of
government and a local or more local
level level of government and that is
because it serves as a check and balance
just as it does on the federal level
there the larger level of government
provides a floor of Rights and then
local governments can build up from
there but not sync beneath it's the same
with State and Municipal so that serves
a
function um um my personal story is
about a month ago and I'm not like the
previous speaker um I I I drive quickly
is is what I will say I have a CDL
license I've been CDL licensed for and I
perhaps the captain should should cover
his ears when I'm speaking about my
driving but I have a CDL license uh yeah
too late indeed um uh I've put nearly a
million miles professionally and in
large CDL vehicles in addition I am a
motorcycle Enthusiast and have
um ridden in multiple States Colorado
California Florida you name it so um
when you put that many miles on you get
a little bit confident and so I am a
fast driver and I was driving pretty
quickly um but not recklessly and not
you know unreasonably beyond the rest of
traffic um on
95 and as I was driving I was in the
passing Lane as I was driving and I was
passing as I was driving I noticed um
that someone came up behind me and was
tailgating me very very very closely and
swerving very aggressively and hosti and
my first instinct was to try to gain
distance he was that close um and then
as I was able to he he stayed right on
me but as I was able to gained some
distance I noticed despite this glare of
the Sun the ever the smallest little
blue tint of a flicker in the headlights
that had previously been invisible to me
because the person was so close behind
me that the headlights were not viewable
they were underneath my rear windshield
view so finally I pulled over all the
way and this person in a Bruins uh
Jersey came out screaming at me he did
not identify himself by name or give me
a badge number or show any
identification at all he simply said he
was a State Trooper by the way this
happened in Massachusetts not New
Hampshire um and he was extremely
hostile with me uh directly yelling at
me and he actually said that he was
about to call um and I don't even know
what this is but he was going to call
for a pullover bar and if it's what I
think it might be it means that he was
willing to have my tires punctured and
in the middle of rush hour traffic I
don't know I don't know it but it was
extremely hostile and after he wrote up
my citation he threw the ticket into my
window so I give you all of this and I
don't want to suggest that New Hampshire
officers are guilty of any of this I've
heard no stories to that effect but I
give you all of this because of the
thought that every occupation attracts a
certain personality type if you like
kids you might decide to be a teacher if
you like helping people maybe you want
to go into nursing for for law
enforcement I hope and I believe that
maybe even a majority of Law Enforcement
Officers got into it because they truly
wanted to see Justice Done in the world
and help people however if you are also
a person who I guess colloquially we
call on a power trip and you feel like
you need to dominate others those people
are also attracted to law enforcement I
grew up in Memphis which was the um
murder and auto theft capital of the
country uh for multiple years as I was
growing up and our car was stolen six
times as I was growing up police
officers in my mind as I was growing up
were the good guys so I don't want to
say it's every officer but when you have
enough people in a department or in a
culture they're they're able to affect
the culture and my question is how much
more for someone who is thinking along
those lines who wants to dominate people
how much more emboldened are they if
they lose the accountability that comes
with showing up and I realize that
uniforms aren't part of this bill but in
uniform and in a marked vehicle
go with I think this is a Spider-Man
quote but with great power comes great
responsibility and they're really in
everyday Society police officers hold
the most power so therefore they have to
be held to the most responsibility on
the previous Bill actually the captain
who I only have respect for I want to
make that very very clear um said and I
I tried to write down the quote as he
was saying it that the department would
oppose quote anything that removes
transparency ownership and culpability
but what else is having a marked vehicle
than the transparency ownership and
culpability of your
actions there's two other quick aspects
to this I I want to bring up
um one is I am a motorcycle Enthusiast
and there has historically been some
relationship both positive and negative
between motorcyclists and the law
enforcement Community generally Cruiser
drivers which I I do ride Cruisers as
well
um are seen favorably sometimes by some
police officers generally sport bike
drivers Riders are uh not um and I
actually sent a video which I'm happy to
share with the committee of an an
unmarked vehicle officer with in plain
clothes um pulling over a motorcyclist
on a sport bike um and approaching the
rider with gun drawn and aimed and aimed
at the writer for no other reason than
speeding so I think that speaks to like
the mentality of certain officers not
all the other thing I want to to speak
to is what uh representative nle brought
up about the relationship between women
who may be alone in their vehicle and
officers um and this is something I
found in 2020 and wanted to do something
about it there was an expose a study
across the country of uh police officers
who engage in police detaining sexual
offense this is where police officer
picks up somebody typically a woman um
cites them for something essentially
threatens to arrest them takes them
around somewhere dark and and uh tells
them to comply or else they will go to
jail um it's legal this is legal because
there's nothing explicitly making it
illegal in 35 States at the time I found
this out I asked a former officer in New
Hampshire if it was legal in this state
and the officer told me no I took his
word for it in preparation for this
testimony I looked it back up it is
legal in the state so I'm going to tell
you right now I intend to Prime sponsor
a bill next year and I welcome any
co-sponsors off of this committee um to
make it illegal but it is uh legal in 35
States for an officer to have sex with a
detainee um so long as they claim it's
consensual there's a power differential
and we have a power differential in much
of our sexual assault uh statute um to
show that that is an exacerbating
influence so I don't think it's okay for
a police officer who has power over a
detainee to um have sex with them across
this country that's getting kind of far
off the bill okay my my point in
bringing it up and I apologize for that
is that with these stories these are
police officers in marked vehicles with
uniforms they're still doing this and it
happens apparently once a week across
the country how much more emboldened are
they if they are not wearing their
uniform and are in a unmarked vehicle is
my question so um again I appreciate the
committee's time uh but I do think it's
something that needs to be taken
seriously and I hope the committee will
work on it thank
you chair calls Chief Paul Dean thanks
any good morning I'll be brief my name
is Paul Dean I'm the chief of police for
the University of New Hampshire and the
third vice president for the New
Hampshire Chiefs associate where they
have speaking on we're we're speaking
we're opposed to this bill I'm not going
to go into a lot of the things that have
already been said um but I've not heard
one example um sitting there of a New
Hampshire officer uh doing doing
something it's been all out of state
people and I think that's important for
the standards that we use to hire law
enforcement officers in the state of New
Hampshire I've been a police officer for
39 years and I'm proud of the New
Hampshire law enforcement profession I'm
proud of police students and training
where we train all officers whether
they're campus police officers state
police officers municipal or county
offices the same and I know in that
training that we are taught how to
identify ourselves when we are in pling
when we are pling
clothes I also want to comment on the
issue of asset forfeiture um the
representative spoke about stopping a
car potentially seizing it and
repurposing it for law enforcement that
that's simply not the case I am not
aware in my 39 years and I worked
undercover for the Attorney General's
office
um for a period of time of we seized
cars but we didn't repurpose them for
use on the road for traffic enforcement
most of the time those were gone to
auction and the money returned uh there
so I just wanted to comment on those
those areas there and that's been said
any Chief with regard to the the points
made by the sponsor and subsequent um
testimony from other people including
and the representative who just
testified do you not think that for the
purposes of traffic enforcement it is
better that our um vehicles used by our
law enforcement are
marked yes sir of course uh but I do
think that there's opportunities for us
to use unmarked vehicles for specific
enforcement in specific enforcement
areas where the unmarked
vehicle may be deterrent but is not able
to stop things that are things that are
happening uh in addition to that um I
drive an unmarked vehicle I can tell you
that I only will stop a vehicle for a
serious
offense and I think that's the vast
majority of people who are in unmarked
vehicles that are doing their jobs and I
want to I want to just take a second to
um address um representative selid when
she talked talked about in in Durham um
we spend a lot of time dealing with
underage drinking and the purchasing of
of underage drinking and part of that is
the transportation of
alcohol
and whether you're a liquor enforcement
officer in an unmarked car uh or a
Durham or university police officer in
an unmarked car we do stop vehicles uh
for that because we're in an undercover
plane close uh manner I would be
concerned that a durm or University
Police Officer um couldn't stop those
cars but a liquor enforcement officer
could or a sheriff's department could
I'm I'm confident
that we can manage these with training
and
policy I'm also confident that
representative finy comes from a good
place when he's when he's doing this I
do think think training can handle that
I think police standards and training
can be helpful in that but I also think
accreditation which is now in the hands
of police standards and training for
many
policy representative Stone thank you Mr
chair and thank you for taking my
question Chief in your experience would
you say there's a distinct value for law
enforcement to have the utilization of
unmarked vehicles in everyday law
enforcement
I think it's a tool and I think you're
right I think there is value to it as in
any tool that law enforcement has to
Chief represent man thank you and thank
you for taking my question is there a
distinction between an unmarked vehicle
and a stealth or ghost
of the distinction might be the cost of
putting those putting those decals on
there I roughly pay about the $1,200 to
have my police cars marked I'm not so
sure that's what that cost for a stealth
vehicle but they are marked um up with
stealth markings um some are reflective
you thank you for your testimony
CH is there wishing to testify on this
bill who has not yet
testified seeing none I'm closing the
public hearing on both of these
bills which are for the record House
Bill 1237 and House Bill 1238 and we are
done for the day and I will see you all
next
Wednesday